get ready here it comes close whoo it's
a good thing we had this defense but
what happens when someone attacks my
cloud infrastructure well no problem
that's why we've got cloud armor wait
armor made of clouds no cloud armor for
Google cloud yeah with Google cloud
armor you can protect your network and
infrastructure against denial of service
attacks monitor security and much more
oh well that sounds like a must-have how
do we get started yeah let's jump right
in
let's start with what is cloud armor and
how does it help cloud armor is a
network security offering for protecting
your Google cloud deployments against
layer 3 through layer 7 DDoS attacks by
leveraging Google's global edge
infrastructure and DDoS defense
expertise cloud armor works with global
HTTP HTTPS load balancer which provides
built-in Infrastructure DDoS defense you
can create rules using combination of
layer 3 to 7 parameters and geolocation
to protect your deployment you can also
use predefined rules to defend against
cross-site scripting and sequel
injection defenses create the policy and
apply to more than one service instead
driver logging you can see if the policy
was matched and applied to the incoming
request you don't always have to apply
the policy and rules in Access or deny
mode you can understand the access
patterns by using preview mode to ensure
you're blocking correct traffic you can
also enforce access control based on
ipv4 and ipv6 addresses or Sider blocks
all right
enough time now let's see how to set up
cloud Armour on Google cloud console
choose network security under networking
and then create policy give your policy
a name select a rule action from allow
and deny then add rule give your rule a
description under conditions choose a
type right now under the beta release
you can select IP address ranges provide
the matching criteria with IP address
range and select the action allow or
deny initially you may want to just
preview the traffic under this rule so
select enable checkbox to just review
priority determines the order in which
the rules are checked so accordingly
we're just gonna set thousand in this
case now the last step is to set up
targets targets are GCP resources that
you want to control access to you will
need to have a predefined load-balanced
target so
like that as one of the targets that you
want you will see the policy create on
the dashboard in order to test if the
policy worked access the backend in
Google Cloud console navigate to start
driver logging
and expand the recent log and you will
see the enforced security policy under
JSON payload there you have it you just
created a simple blacklist policy in
cloud armor and verified that it weren't
in stat driver logging so mark that's
how easy it is to set up cloud armor Wow
with all that security everyone should
be using it to keep the network safe
that's right and you can get started
right now using Google Cloud armor to
protect yourself from attacks whoo don't
forget to Like subscribe and comment
below and if you want to get in
consciousness click the link below
[Music]